ce sixième budget de l'administration
plante atteint un nouveau record 6
milliards 700 000 dollars c'est 30% de
plus qu'en 2017 et il contient la hausse
de taxes la plus significative depuis 11
ans plus 4,1% en moyenne pour le
résidentiel 2,9 pour les commerces et
les industries la cause principale
l'inflation
il faut qu'on continue à offrir les
services aux mariés parce que c'est ce à
quoi il s'attendent mais tous les
arrondissements ne sont pas égaux devant
la hausse des impôts parmi les plus
modérés il y a Ville-Marie Montréal Nord
ou encore Verdun mais les résidents de
L'Île-Bizard Hoche Laga ou code des
neiges verront grimper leur compte de
plus de 5%. alors que l'hypothèque
Hélène s'arrête pas il faut la payer
chaque mois c'est sûr qu'ils vont
refiler le prix donc au locataire en
même temps de tout le reste qui augmente
les gens en plus de misère à soulager
plus de misère à Snow rire l'opposition
se dit jalouse de la ville de Québec ou
la hausse de taxes a été contenue à
2,5%. pourquoi la Ville de Montréal ne
peut pas serrer les dépenses quand on
parle on est en train de serrer les
dépenses et on embauche 646 nouvelles
personnes à la ville il y a un problème
oui on achète légèrement des gens mais
on les ajoute dans des choses concrètes
au service des citoyens et pour pouvoir
avoir des économies plus tard au
chapitre des dépenses 100 millions de
dollars de plus seront consacrés à la
sécurité publique pour embaucher
notamment 123 policiers parmi les
nouveaux revenus grâce au compteur d'eau
Montréal va commencer l'année prochaine
à taxer les grands consommateurs les
entreprises qui utilisent plus de 1000
mètres cubes par an mais au-delà des
taxes il y a aussi des mesures pour
soulager certains portefeuilles celui
des plus de 65 ans par exemple pour qui
bute ces métros seront gratuits à partir
du 1er juillet si Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal